sir how are you I can't believe we're
wearing the same shirt I love that yes
it's it's hate and it's very kind of you
to wear a thing I sent you in the mail
yeah well I I'm pretty easy if you send
me something in the mail I will wear it
and I want to get that message out there
but this has special significance this
shirt tell us about it yes my my family
runs a company called tee Rico and we
sell merch and we made this this is
actually the zip code for Times Square
and Broadway and all proceeds of this
shirt complete with elbow kissing elbows
goes to the Broadway cares
relief fund which helps fund the actress
fund and basically everyone not just
actors but everyone who works in the
theater it's it's an emergency
assistance fund for them since we work
where people gather yeah I mean this is
been devastating so this is a great this
is a great cause I will wear this with
pride
okay it picks up the color in my eyes I
think very nicely yeah it cuz really
that's at the end of the day what's the
most important thing you know so many
things to talk about first of all it's
weird we're in a weird situation right
now we're all separated but there's so
many things that unites us right now
these common experiences one of the
things I've been having very vivid
dreams and then I read in the in an
article that everyone's having vivid
dreams right now I understand you posted
about this you're having weird dreams
yeah I dreamt last night or the night
before I posted on Twitter I dreamt I
was like a grizzled newspaper I didn't
like a JJ Jameson type and my two Star
reporters my Woodward and Bernstein were
Swoosie Kurtz and wrappered the baby
like they couldn't be more different but
I was just like get it to me Mom I just
by five o'clock did you have a little
cigar I was just like I don't know
something about this team I think
they're really good at crack it I wasn't
ready what piece was I just remember no
like I feel like my brain is just
looking around like you get in here you
very young kids and they're playing a
lot with these toys and these little toy
figurines which kids do like animals and
stuff like that but you posted this
picture that is fascinating because it's
a bunch of animals it's all animals I
think and exotic animals yeah and then
the rock is in there for some reason
yeah yeah well he doesn't fit any of the
other toy categories I think it was
actually I think it was a toy I had in
college that just landed in my kids
rotation it's of Dwayne the rock Johnson
when he was a wrestler yeah and he's not
a superhero he doesn't fit with the
Barbies he doesn't so he lives in the
Savannah with the Savannah animals and I
get Pride Rock everywhere which means
that like I'll just walk into a room and
they've set up a pride watch situation
where there's fossa in the middle and
all the animals in an elaborate
arrangement around Texas my shower your
Johnson is always there like sort of
amidst the Zebras and the draft
have you ever reached for a bar of soap
or the loofah in the shower and realize
you were scrubbing yourself with Dwayne
the rock Johnson has that happened I've
not yet had that pleasure but I have
stepped on several small animals man
prymaat